[Musique]
bienvenue dans le duel des éditos votre
émission politique hebdomadaire
au sommaire une question centrale
pourquoi la france peut-elle vers
l'extrême droite à quatre mois de la
présidentielle c'est indéniable la
droite est de retour selon un récent
sondage l'addition des voix de marine le
pen valérie pécresse et eric zemmour
atteindrait 47% tenté par la
radicalisation pour séduire les
partisans des candidats zemmour et le
pen comment la droite est elle devenue
majoritaire chez les français faut-il
s'attendre à une campagne tournée vers
les thèmes de l'immigration et de
l'identité
c'est le débat de la semaine alexis
poule a et jacques de guillebon vous
livrent ensuite leur avis sur une actu
du monde d'après mais d'abord emmanuel
macron s'apprête à devenir président de
l'europe dès le 1er janvier le président
français prendra la tête du conseil
européen pour au moins 4 mois 6 s'il est
réélu alors qu'attendre de cette
présidence emmanuel macron pourra-t-il
insuffler une nouvelle dynamique à une
union européenne mise à mal les
nombreuses crises récentes mais
commençons par une première question
messieurs cette présidence de l'ue eux
c'est plutôt un avantage ou un
inconvénient pour la campagne du
candidat macro
bonjour jacques jean alexis je dirais
que c'est un avantage pour le candidat
macron puisque en 2017 il était un ce
champion européen klaus schwab le disait
ça le meilleur un leader pour cette
europe que nous voulons et donc c'est
pour lui un thème fort il est le
défenseur de l'europe de la construction
de l'union européenne donc devenir
président de l'union européenne en
campagne je pense que c'est un atout
énorme pour lui c'est dommageable parce
que une présidence c'est seulement tous
les quatorze ans pour un pays et je
pense que ce sera une présidence vide en
fait une présidence simplement de
bateleur de foire où il sera là pour
parler aux français plutôt que à tous
les partenaires européens vous parlez
comme eric zemmour en fait en disant que
ce serait une présidence vide que
emmanuel macron est un un président vite
de manière générale je suis d'accord
avec vous c'est plus qu'un avantage -
oui c'est un privilège indu et c'est
assez scandaleux que dans les règles de
l'union européenne on ne prête pas en
compte le fait qu un président ou un
premier ministre les autres pays
puissent être en campagne pendant qu'il
a présidé l'europe c'est à dire qu'il va
jouir de toute cette mise en scène de
l'europe de tous ces chevaux qui vont
être braqués sur lui pour pouvoir faire
sa campagne sachant qu'en plus il ya des
chansons qui sont minimes mais qui
existe quand même qu'ils ne finissent
pas ce mandat alors il dans l'union en
q1 choisir de repousser cette présidence
il a refusé donc il sait très bien ce
qu'il fait il sait très bien le timing
et cette présidence donc pour lui au
contraire je pense que c'est un atout
majeur dans sa campagne alors il n'est
encore pas déclaré candidat mais on voit
que depuis septembre de toute façon il
est en campagne
c'était le cas encore cette semaine à
vierzon et à vichy pour ce qui sera de
bruxelles clairement pour lui il va
pouvoir faire des discours parlé au
monde entier à voir cette stature
internationale qui fait qu'un président
de la république a toujours un temps
d'avancé sur des candidats qui n'ont pas
ce rôle là est donc clairement il a
choisi pour lui pour cette campagne
d'avoir cette présidence oui et c'est
proprement scandaleux moi je trouve
vis-à-vis du reste de la campagne
présidentielle française sachant qu'il a
décidé en plus donc le président du
conseil européen se dire qu'il préside
les réunions de ministres européens il a
décidé de décentraliser ça dans 18
petites villes moyennes villes de france
c'est
absolument profiter pour faire son tour
de france aux frais de l'europe ça va
pas rentrer dans ses frais campagne je
pense on vient vérifier et il va pouvoir
donc se donner ses statuts rui
internationale supérieure dire c'est moi
qui vais régler la question des gars
femmes c'est moi qui vais régler la
question de la taxe carbone c'est moi
qui vais régler la question des entrées
aux frontières et de l'espace schengen
d'ailleurs il faudrait qu'on en discute
de toutes ces questions puisque ça fait
quand même trente ans que cette europe
existe sous cette forme depuis
maastricht chez et on s'aperçoit tout
d'un coup que schengen c'est très
bizarre comme comme lieu parce qu'il
n'ya pas de la personne qui garde les
frontières alors que n'importe quel pays
depuis mille ans et garder ses
frontières que on va mettre des
policiers à l'intérieur de schengen mais
sans rétablir les frontières donc en
fait cette europe est en train d'essayer
de se réinventer sous le sous le coup du
réel mais trente ans après je pense que
philippe séguin avait déjà d'il ya
trente ans que ça n'allait pas marcher
oui les français d'ailleurs en 2005
avait voté un il ya un moment il faut
arrêter ça peut être un outil de
coopération un outil de collaboration
entre états aujourd'hui c'est un outil
de deux compétitions c'est un outil
aussi inefficace on l'a vu dans la crise
sanitaire les premiers mois aucune
réponse coordonnée ça a été très
compliqué et la seule réponse finalement
coordonnées ça a été l'achat en masse de
vaccins avec ursula von der leyen qui
refuse toujours de d'échangés lé contenu
de ces sms partager avec albert mollat
le patron de pfizer et puis la question
migratoire ça fait des années que
l'europe est incapable de régler cette
question migratoire à l'époque de jean
claude juncker président de la
commission européenne y était question
de quotas ça n'a jamais été respectée
chaque pays essaye d'avoir le beau rôle
en dix ans mais nous on fait tout ce
qu'on peut vous comprenez les conseils
se suivent et aucun homme aucune
solution ne sort du chapeau donc il faut
se poser la question à un moment à quoi
ça sert sans compter que la cour des
comptes européenne est sous le feu de
vives critiques puisqu'il ya eu des
débordements à la façon dont certains
fonctionnaires européens s'octroient des
droits que même ici des ministres
n'oserait pas s'octroyer donc vraiment
et il est temps de faire le ménage et je
crois pas qu'elle macron aura six mois
pour ça au contraire il va utiliser
cette stature européenne pour écraser
les candidats français à l'élection
présidentielle oui c'est ça ça crée une
concurrence totalement déloyale à
l'intérieur de la de la campagne
présidentielle française il va pouvoir
et or qui est tous les autres candidats
regardez-moi je en train de travailler
au niveau de l'europe pour régler ces
problèmes justement d'immigration qui
sont qui vont être le sujet enfin qui
sont déjà le sujet de de la campagne
présidentielle française il va leur
expliquer que voilà lui c'est comment
fonctionne frontex cuisse et comment on
va arrêter des migrants lui à se donner
les moyens de faire ça et donc il ya
vraiment on va être à deux étages de
différent et je pense que d'un point de
vue de la loi française c'est proprement
scandaleux qu'ils aient le droit d'avoir
cette stature pendant qu'il est en
campagne alors on parle avant
l'allocution du président fasse sa
conférence de presse de cet après midi
donc on ne sait pas quelles sont les
stratégies les axes qu'il va dégager
pour cette présidence de l'union
européenne mais clairement on est
d'accord globalement cette présidence
sera un outil essentiel dans sa
déclaration de candidature est dans sa
campagne et d'ailleurs comme vous
l'aviez fait remarquer ici déjà il donne
jamais de conférence de presse emmanuel
macron il a déjà donné la voir dans tout
ce mandat là qu'il en donne une
aujourd'hui il ya l'importance de cette
présidence de l'union européenne mais il
ya aussi les circonstances électorales
les républicains qui viennent de définir
leur candidate toute la droite qui monte
il a besoin je pense de se réaffirmer de
redonner un rôle comme ça de presque
candidat et c'est ce qui va faire à mon
avis dans cette conférence de presse
[Musique]
place au débat de la semaine
républicaine ou extrêmes la droite
polarise le débat public et le paysage
médiatique
les candidats portant ses idées
rassemble une bonne partie des
estimations de vote dans les sondages
alors la france serait-elle un pays de
droite voire d'extrême droite face à une
gauche historiquement basses dans les
sondages macron doit-il entamé ligne
encore plus à droite mais ouvrons le
débat avec la nouvelle candidate dlr
selon vous quelle doit être la stratégie
gagnante pour valérie pécresse a rameuté
le centre droit macro nist ou tenter la
récupération des sionistes
[Musique]
à l'évidence si valérie pécresse est
intelligente et dépasse son idéologie
qui est plutôt qu'il amène plutôt vers
le centrisme elle un intérêt à aller
chercher ce qu'on appelle les sionistes
aujourd'hui depuis depuis une semaine on
savait pas que ça existait avant les
sionistes mais en tout cas cette cette
frange des républicains qui restent
encore dans le parti des républicains et
qui a voté qui a mis comme eric ciotti
au premier tour ce qui est quand même
c'est quand même énorme et qu'il a
portée quand même à 40% au second tour
parce que ça prouve quoi ça prouve que
depuis au moins 15 ans mon avis depuis
yeux nicolas sarkozy en 2007 la droite a
tendance à aller plus à droite et donc
je tairai pas se radicaliser mais en
tout cas clarifier la situation et à
s'assumer vraiment de droite on l'avait
vu aussi avec françois fillon en 2017
qui a été portée quand même à la tête de
la primaire par une grande frange de
gens issus la manif pour tous les cas de
cette droite conservatrice là on parle
de 4 millions d'électeurs pour la
primaire on n'est pas sur cent cinquante
mille ha oui ce ne sont pas les mais on
voit quand même enfin quand on voit ce
que ce qu'ils aiment ou reprend comme
comme électorat marine le pen qui baisse
assez peu qu'on arrive presque à 50%
d'une france qu'on peut dire à droite
c'est évident que si elle veut aller se
faire élire à l'intérêt allait marcher
sur ses plates-bandes et à récupérer ce
qu'ils aiment on a pu le prendre comme
électorat c'est à dire un électorat
plutôt aisée conservateur bourgeois est
très attaché oui au conservatisme et
olivo chose qui reste si elle va sur les
plates-bandes emmanuel macron elle prend
le risque d'être moins légitime que lui
parce qu'il est parce qu il est déjà là
et de retomber dans les erreurs de du
centre droit que les français droite des
tests depuis les mon avis 15 ans je
crois qu'effectivement stratégiquement
le choix est clair elle a tout intérêt à
se démarquer des manuels macron donc à
ne pas aller draguer cet électorat là
dans un premier temps mais au contraire
réaffirmé la vague surtees est enfin
tout ce qui avait mis en place laurent
wauquiez et fillon lors de la campagne
de 2010 est parce que les idées les
débats qu'on a eu pour le congrès sont
ceux du programme de 2010 est de
françois fillon à quelques exceptions
près mais voilà où on en est aujourd'hui
donc l'état des lieux et la 40% pour etc
se tissent est énorme elle n'a que 60 %
alors que tous les autres candidats
soutenait finalement valérie pécresse au
deuxième tour du congrès donc elle n'a
pas le choix finalement de faire ça mais
elle a un vocabulaire qui peut poser
question puisque à propos de d'eric
ciotti on va l'écouter elle parle de
d'ajouter du piment finalement à son
programme la droite est de retour la
droite est de retour et il ya une
formidable équipe de france qui s'est
levé dans cette primaire des
républicains
une droite qu'on attendait plus et dans
cette droite il y a une personnalité
singulière une personnalité singulière
qui s'appelle eric ciotti avec arrêt que
nous avons aussi en partage la volonté
réformatrice
alors il va plus loin que moi
sur certains thèmes
et donc je vais regarder si mon projet
peut être pimenté par un certain nombre
de ces suggestions
voilà c'était à nice 1 dans les terres
d'eric ciotti justement juste après la
victoire pour s'assurer de l'unité de
l'union qu'elle ne soit pas de façade
dont je ne sais pas ce que va demander
dans cette campagne eric ciotti puisque
ça va être extrêmement important
pimentez ça me paraît peut-être pas
assez un peu léger pour ce qui va être
finalement de définir une ligne
programmatique et des mesures fortes qui
vont être celle du droit du sol par
exemple on voit bien que là il ya quand
même une fracture est essentielle et
puis d'autres d'autres questions sur
l'ordre du régalien grande tanawa la
française je crois pas que valérie
pécresse serait tout à fait d'accord
avec cette idée là ou non je suis pas
sûr que ce soit souhaitable mieux
possible dans toute façon en france mais
ce qui est très étrange chez son
vocabulaire quand elle dit on et
réformistes à gauche réformiste plutôt
dire on n'est pas révolutionnaire donc
on va plutôt vers le centre on et social
démocrate elle l'a congédie nous sommes
réformistes ou les deux eric ciotti et
moi ça veut dire on se radicalise on
veut réformer la droite justement
changer de vie car wayne changer le
droit du sol changer la préférence
nationale et donc c'est elle vient
d'inventer un nouveau sens au terme
réformiste à droite va se positionner
plus à droite mais pour l'instant ce
sont des déclarations qui allait obliger
de faire parce qu'elle est un peu prise
en otage par eric ciotti électorat qui
représente on n'est pas certain de sa
sincérité pour l'instant elle ne faut
pas oublier que valérie pécresse avait
quand même quitté les républicains en
disant que laurent wauquiez qui est
d'ailleurs le grand perdant de cette de
cette primaire
radicaliser la droite et qu'il allait
trop à droite maintenant elle est
obligée quelques années après de venir
sur ses marchés ses plates-bandes et de
dire la même chose que ce qu'ils
disaient qu'elle lui reprocher de dire
mais je crois que c'est tout le problème
de la sincérité et aussi de
l'incarnation de cette droite là parce
que on préféra toujours l'original à la
copie et beaucoup d'électeurs militants
qui ont voté pour la mouvance scientiste
eux vont sans doute si jamais valérie
pécresse dérives trop vers le centre
droit préféré aller voir eric zemmour si
sa campagne prend et qu'il va réussir à
lancer quelque chose est clairement déjà
au sein des républicains la fracture est
là guillaume pelletier monsieur périodes
qui ont dit voilà le discours de zemmour
nous fait vibrer et se font exclure le
lendemain parce qu'ils ont osé dire que
ce discours là les séduisait donc il ya
une cassure profonde valérie pécresse va
tout faire pour ne pas la montrer pour
ne pas la mettre en scène mais les
réelles et ça va être difficile pour
elle d'avoir une stratégie crédible
alors qu'elle avait quitté ce parti
parce qu'ils étaient trop à droite et
d'incarner une ligne de droite dure
alors qu'il ya une offre de droite dure
beaucoup plus forte du côté d'eric
zemmour c'est vrai pression sur
guillaume pelletier qu'il n'a pas été
exclu mais qu'il a été déchargé de son
sa vice-présidence des républicains port
a déclaré ça et que guillaume pelletier
est assez coutumier du fait c'est pour
ça qu'on le surnomme d'ailleurs le
variant français voilà la tendance à
passer d'un camp à l'autre de manière
assez leste avec le même pseudo
sincérité
mais le faut pas négliger non plus chez
chez valérie pécresse le fait qu'elle
est comme soutenu par cette gigantesque
machine qui s'appelle les républicains
qui existent encore quoi qu'on en dise
et ça se voit peut-être dans les
sondages qui sont sortis depuis son
élection même si le sondage est la pila
donne à 20% ensemble qui a fait grimper
de 11 points qui a fait beaucoup rire
d'ailleurs jean-luc mélenchon est
peut-être un peu surestimé il ya quand
même une montée de cette droite qu'on
pouvait croire enterré par les
candidatures concurrentes de marine le
pen et d'eric zemmour il reste quand
même un socle comme on le voit notamment
dans les alpes-maritimes cher eric
ciotti comme on voit dans certains
endroits de france un socle d'un
électorat qui est assez âgé ça il faut
le dire vite donc il va plus voter qui
est plus fidèle et qui reste légitimiste
malgré tout donc qui peut conserver son
vote pour valérie pécresse quand bien
même elle aurait des propositions moins
- charpenté et moins sincère que celles
qui sont donnés par eric zemmour et par
marine oui mais il ya aussi un fait
enfin le sondage un récent qui montre
une france de droite en quelque sorte où
les français disent naturellement est
plutôt de droite ou du centre ou ne pas
trop savoir mais on voit bien que la
gauche on ne sait plus trop ce que c'est
en france donc c'est compliqué et là il
ya peut-être aussi cette droite radicale
trop visible sur les réseaux sociaux
dans les médias aussi qui serait une
erreur parce que le coeur de l'électorat
celui qu'on appelle à la france
silencieuse enfin qui votent mais qui ne
participent pas plus que ça aux débats
il est quand même globalement de
centre-droit c'était le pari fait par
mails macro paris qu'il a gagné et
aujourd'hui les républicains s'ils ont
des régions des départements des villes
c'est pas sur une base d'un programme
ultra radicale à la eric ciotti qui
permet certes de pimenter comme le dit
valérie pécresse mais qui ne fera pas le
gros de l'électorat donc c'est là où la
stratégie va être plus délicate surtout
si le deuxième tour les met face à face
dernier sondage là encore on peut
commenter en se posant des questions
mais qui met valérie pécresse devant
emmanuel macron second tour oui mais
vous comparez avec 2010 m quand ils
emmanuel macron et est élu je pense
qu'il s'est quand même passé des choses
depuis la voilà que les français sont
encore plus à droite qu'avant ne serait
ce parce que y voit le réel et que la
droite et est censé incarner leurs ailes
enfin en tout cas c'est ce que je pense
moi et et dans ce sens là les
républicains
locaux ceux qui ont gagné notamment des
élections régionales municipales etc ce
sont des gens qui ont une pensée
beaucoup plus incarner conservatrice est
plus à droite que ce que peuvent être
les instances ont des républicains dans
que les gens les ont peut-être aussi
réélu pour ça parce qu'ils étaient plus
proches de leurs préoccupations et donc
il reste quand même ce socle là qui est
à mon avis beaucoup plus à droite que ce
qu'imaginent les caciques et des
républicains il ya quand même une
question éludée un systématiquement
c'est le rapport à l'union européenne on
revient ce dont on parlait puisque la
présence française certes mais qu'est ce
qu'on veut faire de ces traités si on
veut mettre en place une réforme de la
politique migratoire une réforme de la
fiscalité
il va falloir aussi réformer en
profondeur l'union européenne alors là
on a l'impression que on va faire la
même chose avec les mêmes périmètres or
la question fondamentale c'est est ce
qu'on peut récupérer une part de
souveraineté est-ce qu'on peut récupérer
une part de liberté alors dans l'euro
c'est plus compliqué ça protège d'une
certaine façon d'avoir cette monnaie
unique mais c'est aussi un problème on
l'a vu en grèce par exemple là c'est une
question qui a été enlevé très loin il
ya michel barnier qui était monsieur bré
que sita qui est venu qui a dit oui il
faut vraiment réformer lui voulait la
politique des quotas migratoires et un
référendum et puis bien sûr la question
de la démocratie un récent sondage aussi
montré que les français s'inquiétait de
l'état de la démocratie en france avec
en cinq ans un effondrement du débat
démocratique le fait que les
contre-pouvoirs sont inutiles on a vu
que ce soit conseil d'état conseil
constutionnel l'assemblée nationale qui
est en jambes et par un exécutif tout
puissant cette question là aussi de
remettre la démocratie les gilet jaune
qu'il apportait avec le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne là on parle de
référendum sur quelques sujets mais ce
n'est pas suffisant et on a l'impression
que les grandes questions sont un peu
éludé et on va parler de sujets où on
est d'accord pour que valérie pécresse
se met en scène comme une opposante à
maquereau mais qui ferait la même
politique in fine et c'est bien ça le
problème c'est vrai ça et notamment sur
la démocratie directe que vous dites
c'est que c'est ça provoque un effet
pervers c'est à dire que des gens se
disent puisque ma voix n'est pas
entendue je ne vais plus aller voter
donc je pense qu'on va avoir une
abstention qui va croître en france et
ce qu'on voit pour l'instant dans les
sondages par rapport aux mêmes maux
dernière présidentielle qui sont
pourtant les élections qui généralement
rameute le plus de monde et stimule le
plus le vote des français donc ça va
encore baisser donc il va vers une
france silencieuse qui va grandir qui
ont envie d'être au moins de 30% qui
n'aura pas donné son avis dont c'est
facile et droite de gauche du centre
détroit où elle ne s'est pas non plus et
domaine sur l'union européenne c'est
peut-être d'ailleurs l'intérêt
paradoxale de la conférence de presse
que peut donner emmanuel macron tout à
l'heure c'est que remettant ce sujet sur
la table ça va forcer peut-être les
autres candidats à en parler et
notamment à droite c'est quand même la
chose qui coupe la droite depuis
longtemps depuis ses gains chirac
notamment depuis maastricht entre ceux
qui sont voilà qui sont hostiles à
l'union européenne telle qu'elle est
faite ceux qui pensent que et qu'elle
nous protège et valérie pécresse mon
avis va être bien ça est bien délicat
pour elle de devoir trancher entre
autres cette remise en cause de l'europe
et pour rassurer son électorat justement
sur le même plutôt vieillissant et
attachée à l'europe et qui croient que
c'est elle qui le protège à la fois que
c'est le grand écart et il est très
difficile à tenir en réalité à un moment
il ya aussi un désir de rupture on le
voit la demande d'autorités ça aussi
mais c'est une autorité factice tant que
l'autorité à bruxelles tant qu'on va
continuer à faire ces choses là et la
demande cette demande de débat elle
n'est pas anodine c'est à dire que le
succès du congrès c'est aussi ça s'est
montré qu'un débat interne ne peut
fonctionner ça a marché pour les l'air
mais c'est la synthèse qui sort de sa
est la synthèse on sait ce que ça fait
ça a fait que le parti socialiste a été
hégémonique pendant des années puis il
s'est effondré sur cette synthèse parce
qu'à un moment on ne sait plus qu'est ce
que représente finalement cette mouvance
politique qui n'en est plus une puisque
c'est de la gestion en obéissant aux
traités européens en étant toujours dans
la salle oui c'est ce qui cache un autre
débat interne à la droite dont personne
n'est pas le pour l'instant c'est
libéralisme antilibérale hispania que
marine le pen qui se met plutôt sur une
ligne antilibérale valérie pécresse et
eric zemmour sont sur la même ligne
libérale c'est à dire on va baisser les
cotisations sociales on va relancer
l'entreprise n'importe quel risque alors
que c'est une fracture qui habite la
droite depuis longtemps et personne pour
l'instant n'a l'intention de régler
cette question oui bah évidemment ça
fait partie de ces gros de thèmes et qui
ne sont pas évoqués parce qu'il fâchent
mais il va bien falloir à un moment que
valérie pécresse arbitres et qu'elle
sorte un programme
[Musique]
direction le monde d'après alexis poule
a et jacques de guillebon vous apportent
leur éclairage chaque semaine sur une
information qui pourrait faire
l'actualité politique de demain
commençons par vous alexis selon vous
quelles infos mérite cette semaine un
coup de projecteur
alors moi pour cette semaine j'ai choisi
la démission d'alain griset ministres du
gouvernement qui est-il voilà alors
c'était le ministre aux pme il
démissionne mercredi c'était la première
fois qu'un ministre était jugé par un
tribunal correctionnel
c'est vrai que les ministres du
gouvernement macro on les découvre soit
quand ils attrapent locaux vides soit
quand il démissionne c'est un peu
compliqué et là on comprend qu'il y en a
quand même au delà de cette démission
cinq autres ministres qui sont
aujourd'hui mis en examen qui ont
affaire à la justice eric dupond moretti
bien sûr le garde des sceaux qui est mis
en examen pour prise illégale d'intérêts
olivier du soft qui ministre aux comptes
publics lui aussi prise illégale
d'intérêts et corruption à l'époque où
il gérait une commune sébastien lecornu
qu'on a connue récemment ministre d
outre-mer qui était président du conseil
départemental de l'eure et qui a occupé
un poste à la société d'autoroute paris
normandie là encore un problème de prise
illégale d'intérêt et gérald darmanin
même si la juge d'instruction en
septembre a dit que l'instruction a été
close donc c'était pour des accusations
de viol en l'air avant seulement mis en
examen smith que vous citez résolument
perdre et contrairement à glee ce
mois-là grise et démissionne parce qu'il
a été condamné mais il vous est aussi le
mythe de la santé olivier ferrand qui
fait l'objet d'une instruction suite à
sa gestion de la crise du coc vide de la
cour de justice de la république et
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque il y avait une
jurisprudence balladur c'est à dire
qu'un ministre mis en examen devait
quitter son poste aujourd'hui sous de
macron c'est une fois qu'il est condamné
qu'il quitte son poste mais pourtant il
y à françois bayrou qui avait été
obligée de démissionner très rapidement
de son poste de ministre de la justice
et on est très loin de l'image qu'avait
données mails macron de ce nouveau monde
de transparence politique et qui était
attendu avec finalement beaucoup
d'affaires et beaucoup d'affaires aussi
au sein de la majorité des députés qui
sont accusés de violence même certains
de trafic de drogue d'élus de la
majorité donc vraiment un ménage qui n'a
pas été fait contrairement à ce que
prétendait emmanuel macron lors de sa
campagne comme il ce nouveau monde n'est
pas si nouveau que ça dans ses méthodes
dont dix aux méthodes anciennes habituel
en revanche la gauche et c'est une
nouvelle méthode je vais vous parler
c'est cette idée de primaires de la
gauche qui a lancé anne hidalgo
au 20 heures pour essayer de se dépêtrer
de du marasme dans lequel elle est quand
même été sondé à 3% ou plus bas et entre
3 et 5% c'est une chute perpétuelle pour
le maire de paris depuis depuis qu'elle
a lancé sa candidature ce qui n'est pas
pour étonner grand monde surtout quand
en janvier à paris et donc elle essaye
de se dépêtrer de ça en appelant donc à
une primaire de toute la gauche à qui
pense-t-elle elle pense à arnaud
montebourg qui lui-même est encore plus
bas qu'elle dans les sondages qui est
tout à fait prêt à se risquer à cette
candidature à laquelle d'une perdra rien
en revanche voilà les verts avec yannick
jadot qui ont déjà fait leurs primaires
n'ont aucune intention de s'y plier jean
luc mélenchon que ça pourrait
éventuellement arranger c'est comme ça
il pourrait être le le grand maître de
la gauche puisqu'il serait celui qui
gagnerait à priori puisque c'est lui qui
le plus haut dans les sondages ne veut
pas s'y plier non plus et on entendu
quoi philippe poutou vous dire que l'ue
peut être livrés y participer mais on
n'avait pas pensé à lui malheureusement
donc mais fabien roussel du parti
colonial mais
arnaud montebourg voilà faisons à
un redressement productif non mais le
problème de cette hypothétique union de
la gauche c'est que si vous additionnez
des faibles pourcentages 2 + 3 % ça fait
pas forcément ça peut faire en quatre ou
trois et on voit que ces deux campagnes
fantôme celle d'hidalgo et d'arnaud
montebourg il fallait le débrancher
d'une façon ou d'une autre c'est cette
façon là qui a été trouvée de dire du
côté de montebourg j'offre ma
candidature à qui la veut du côté
d'hidalgo faisons une primaire
puisqu'elle existe déjà alors que elle
décrit hier cette même primaire quelques
heures auparavant quelques semaines
auparavant il ya vraiment un amateurisme
une impréparation du camp de gauche à
cette élection présidentielle sauf du
côté parce que n'oublions pas qu'il ya
le grand sauveur de la gauche qui est
christiane taubira con mais qui sont
quand même un peu le délégué un destin
de la gauche qu'on nous ressort à chaque
fois quand la gauche est en train de
mourir et d'attribuer la primaire de la
gauche est déjà un véhicule pour pousser
une candidature de christiane taubira
qui se faisait attendre donc là
peut-être qu'elle va sortir du bois
poulet riz s'appelle saint louis de ses
pairs pour les couleurs phares mais
clairement et personne n'est préparé
sauf je le disait jean luc mélenchon qui
lui un plan de marathonien qui a lancé
son programme vendu son programme qui
enchaîne les meetings etc pour les
autres on a l'impression que la campagne
s'est passé à la télé de temps en temps
à les voir des élus qui rejoignent la
campagne et faire une conférence ça et
là mais elle est une existence y compris
pour yannick jadot que j'ai du mal à
voir
médiatiquement parlant habiter une
campagne de élevé oui parce qu'ils n'ont
rien à dire encore une fois c'est à dire
que les sujets qui ont été imposées par
la droite qui sont ceux de l'immigration
sur la sécurité ce l'identité la gauche
ne sait pas comment les prendre ne sais
pas comment en parler et donc se
rétrécit que me comme peau de chagrin la
gauche doit être 20% aujourd'hui ce qui
est quand même moins de 104 peut-être
d'amérique surnommé oui mais ce qui est
quand même pathétique déjà parce qu'une
partie des électeurs est parti chez
emmanuel macron qui fait plus sérieux et
meilleurs gestionnaires pour la gauche
bourgeoise disons way et et pour le
reste cela il n'ya pas deux il ya aucune
réponse à ce qu'ils sont les
préoccupations actuelles des français et
croire que les trois présents une
élection vont soucier plus de la fin du
monde c'est à dire les questions
écologiques
la fin du mois c'est se tromper c'est
sans doute une erreur c'est un problème
de la démocratie sans doute mais pour
l'instant c'est ça que les gens veulent
me je crois que stratégiquement aussi
c'est une crise de la social démocratie
en france c'est à dire qu'on peut pas
avoir trois candidats qui sont les mêmes
on le savait dès le début est aussi une
crise fondamentale du parti socialiste
qui a trahi finalement les idées de
gauche pour beaucoup d'électeurs de
gauche ou après l'épisode hollande on
s'est dit plus jamais le parti
socialiste donc la question de la gauche
de gouvernement cette social-démocratie
à la française elle est aujourd'hui bien
malade elle aura bien du mal alors on
regarde du côté allemand disant bravo
olaf scholz c'est un peu la gauche c'est
clairement la droite mais du coup en
france ça va être beaucoup plus
compliqué pour eux pensent que les
malades depuis mai 1983 peut-être cette
gauche mais on reviendra là dessus une
prochaine fois avec plaisir à voir
lexique doha jacques
c'est la fin du duel des éditos vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur notre site rt france point tv
et en podcast sur toutes les plateformes
vous pouvez également réagir dans les
commentaires et sur les réseaux sociaux
via le hashtag ldd eux à la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau duel des
éditos
[Musique]